picking up where we left off in last
night's angle we're looking into the
role former Obama officials played in
setting an Intel trap against the Trump
team with a dam of evidence now bursting
former Obama officials are trying to
muddy the waters by sowing confusion
here's a case in point is there anything
in the dossier that has been disproven
no some of it hasn't been proven and
some of it hasn't been no I guess the
answer the short answer the question the
the salacious stuff absolutely no
corroboration of that to my knowledge
nothing's been disproved how do you know
he hasn't been the director of the
National Intelligence for a year and a
half and that's actually the opposite of
the truth none of the wild claims in the
dossier have been proven not publicly
you can bet if any of it were true it
would have been leaked by now there was
a leak in the stuff that they think is
bad for Trump clappers statements
statement isn't even accurate the
dossier incorrectly claimed Michael
Cohen went to Prague to meet with the
Russians of course he's never been to
Prague no public evidence of that looked
at his passport etc but never mind the
facts what's really telling about
clappers remark is that he gives away
the deep state strategy what is it what
is basically create so much doubt in
confusion that Americans give up trying
to make sense of any of it to that end
clapper and fellow Obama alums are
pushing the line that if the dossier
can't be disproved it must be true like
when did you stop beating your wife well
let's discuss how well that strategy
will work in light of all the recent
developments with former CIA analyst and
counter-terror operations officer John
Kiriakou Republican Congressman Steve
Russell of the House Oversight Committee
and former Deputy Assistant Attorney
General Robert Driscoll congressman this
is wild I mean the neverending media
appearances by Jim clapper we were
joking earlier like he must be promoting
a book and indeed he is promoting a book
but what's your take on what he said
right there I think it just shows that
this is really a house of cards where
they're trying to make something that's
they have no evidence of and when they
talk about people being guilty it has
none
thing to do with collusion I think the
American people they see right through
this it is a continual straw man
argument and they're gonna continue to
push it every way they can meeting at
the White House today with a are they
calling it it's always the gang of eight
why don't I got the mob of eight the
gang of it it's not clear what documents
were actually presented to Devin Nunez
or to trey gowdy were they able to
actually look at the document ELLs of
the meeting will not be released because
tight-lipped about well and all of those
that were present as they should be but
I think the bigger concern is is that
will will Devin Nunez and trey gowdy and
others be able to actually get the
information to look at the information
without redaction you know we see these
problems where they will redact things
withholding it from Congress well since
1814 and the Oversight and Government
Committee we we have that responsibility
nothing should be redacted from Congress
they need to get to the facts but Robert
this is what Adam Schiff said about the
meeting let's watch nothing we heard
today has changed our view that there is
no evidence to support any allegation
that the FBI or any intelligence agency
placed a spy in the Trump campaign or
otherwise failed to follow appropriate
procedures and protocols but apparently
they actually didn't have the access to
the documents that they wanted at least
it's not clear that they did and so how
is he coming as like well nothing we saw
well apparently they didn't see all the
documents again and what I took from
what he said was it's very carefully
worded statement he said no evidence
that they placed a spy in the campaign
now
that could still mean you had a
confidential informant contact people in
the campaign right and record the
conversation actually have an office
tower that means they didn't have an
embed in the campaign okay I get that
but I don't think that's necessarily
what's the most concern to Congress so I
think what Sinjin to me is that Trump
could declassify all this stuff himself
with the stroke of a pen it's actually
showing a little bit deference to DOJ by
he's always playing a mediating role
between two branches of government
rather than acting as the head of the
executive branch saying look you know
Congress has got a point there needs to
be more transparency here I'm not gonna
force you to disclose everything because
there may be some interests that are so
strong it's just fine honest reasons for
redaction but things like I couldn't get
over the the $70,000 conference room
table that Andrew McCabe bought was one
of the read action doesn't give out Ben
Carson's wife for the table she got yeah
well how much was that that was eleven
thousand you got a seventy then where do
they get their tables then the trust is
really bad they gotta go to like this
storehouse or whatever they come on John
let's talk to you leave been talking a
lot about the overreach of the
surveillance state I did a big piece on
this last night since 9/11
I guess law all these good intentions
we're gonna keep the nation safe of
course we all want to keep the nation
safe all of us but we have created a
surveillance super state in this country
and I think there are a lot of good
people and all these agencies they put
their lives on the line for us but
people at the top also think they're
beyond reproach and they're so confident
that they're right they want to do what
they want to do with impunity and that's
the deep state I'm glad that you keep
calling it the deep State because it
exists you don't have to call it the
deep state you can call it the federal
bureaucracy but it's there it's
unelected and it's in power forever
people have to remember that that those
those Patriots at the CIA the FBI NSA
and elsewhere many of them came of age
and and entered it to the senior
intelligence service during the Obama
administration and for many of them
that's where their loyalties lie so yeah
there really is a deep state the
congressmen made a very important point
to and that's about congressional
oversight the CIA just as a part of its
very nature pushes back on congressional
oversight and they'll provide to
Congress as little as they can get away
with
that's where Congress has to fight for
its rightful role in oversight and you
were put in jail for 30 months you
leaked the information about the
waterboarding yes correct
it's a long story and it and in most the
charges were dropped one one remained
but you've you felt what happened when
you decided to say this it didn't seem
right to you
and
as a walk I don't lose sleep about
waterboarding and people don't care
about degrees but but but you feel that
the way things have developed in this
country with the explosion of the Intel
agencies that it's very hard for
congressman Russell and Devin Nunez trey
Gowdy and frankly for Democrats if they
were honest to actually say okay what's
going on here like you got these sites
these renditions sites in Pakistan any
of it
what's happening here and they don't
want to salute natural tension and it
always has been there but it's worse the
bigger the Intel state is the super
state the harder it is correct and it
correct
and remember that it got far worse
during the Obama administration John
Brennan at the White House had what
former colleagues of mine have described
as a Nixonian obsession with leaks where
where he was the driving force between
the eight Espionage Act cases that the
Obama Justice Department brought against
people in the intelligence community
that's nearly three times the number of
Espionage Act cases as all previous
presidents combined and it wasn't really
about those individuals it was about
sending a message to the rest of the
intelligence community to keep your
mouths don't you dare don't you dare
exactly that's a little mafia ask
congressman and and Robert I want me
both to respond what you can see where
this is going
the the the left is trying to find these
side issues to grasp on to I don't think
informants in a campaign or trying to
make contact with the campaign as a side
issue I do think it's a side issue and
they say oh the president's lawyer and
the chief of staff were at a meeting for
a short period of time they were
freaking out about this today let's
watch I was stunned when I heard that
Emmitt flood attended even if he wasn't
there for the classified part of it that
he would even show his presence the
presence of Emmitt flood even if it was
just to make introductory remarks
clearly now creates a conflict what we
saw in that meeting today was improper
and it was unprecedented and it does
risk undermining parts of the Malheur
probe I don't know if these people know
anything about the law and the flood was
there to say we're here
we want to help we want we want
transparency we're cooperating with in
up one want to take a positive role in
this and they stayed apparently
different a short period of time they
were gone
congressman it's that it's the typical
prom to like play book it meant nothing
deny everything make counter-accusations
put up some shiny object distract on the
the faction prop the like playbook yes
love it isn't that fun Robert again it's
kind of commonplace I mean the the
president again is playing a mediating
role in this and I think all that
happened was flood was there at the
beginning said would the president
really wants you guys to release as much
as you can
transparency and then they walked out
prior to the classified portion of the
briefing as my understand did the
meeting and he was like okay calling on
you and you have to pick a branch right
and J work for the president and so it's
not inappropriate for the President and
white House Counsel to say prior to the
meeting you work for us here's where the
boss wants to go with this he wants
maximum transparency while still
protecting what is a likelihood that
only one informant this hapless helper
apparently this is whatever this
professor is the only person who was
tasked with some type of outreach to the
Trump campaign doesn't that seem odd
that it was just one guy I mean maybe it
was but that's kind of lame if it's if
they're really wanting to get answers
the guy the Australian contact was the
one that you know always was a question
to me because I mean I've been in a lot
of bars with a lot of people who said a
lot of stupid stuff and the notion that
I would run to the FBI or run to an
intelligence agency based on a
late-night conversation with somebody in
a bar in London seems kind of strange to
me I mean maybe that's that is totally
innocent and he just has a hair-trigger
for when to run to analysis agency but
that I don't think that's common
behavior and that might be worthy of
take a look at what I just think they
have to bring more people to testify on
Capitol Hill or almost out of time but
I'm bringing more people back Susan Rice
has got to come back I bring all these
people back I bring a liver at a Lynch
I'd bring that Oleg Deripaska that
Russian billionaire that they were
making contact with trying to get him to
agree to this collusion narrative he
left him out of this apartment in New
York I'd get all these people back we're
not getting the answers we deserve and
bring the people back to testify they
don't want to testify that tells us a
lot Samantha power bring her in she
never testified at all I don't believe
right congressman I don't believe she
was ever up there